also Sexual Energy as well guys that's a
big one like
you don't know about this okay I'm not
going to say no because like yeah okay
you can wear a condom and it'll protect
you in in one way from STDs or creating
life and whatever but no condom is going
to protect you from transferring energy
it's an actual energy exchange ritual if
it makes sense
where two people become one yeah
yeah
um I have a question for you and you
don't you don't have to answer this um
the the two abortions was it the same
dad
no there are two different two different
people yeah and what made you think you
couldn't have a kid with those guys
um but like what she said it made me
realize what Ruth said it just made me
realize um
this was when I was younger by the way
so I've grown up a lot from how old with
each one so I was
17 on the first one and then I was
um 23. on the next one
um but yeah it just made me realize like
the the the second the first time like I
actually like I was actually having fun
right so that made me calm down I was
like I'm doing that so when you say
having fun it was like a casual it was a
casual so it wasn't anyone you were
serious with no and so okay so then you
thought I can't have a kid with them
right yeah but but that made me realize
right the media it's those they kind of
project that onto people that the
original family is like the perfect
picture I'm but it's not true I've seen
fathers who are not biological and and
they have the most amazing beautiful
families right so
um do you think he would have like stuck
around or no uh no no okay are we spoken
about that yeah it was a and he said if
you have this I won't be there yeah yeah
yeah was he angry at you at all
um
I guess yeah there was some sort of like
you know
pose and whatnot but yeah I guess again
I was quite immature uh mentally at that
time and obviously the second time as
well it
emotion mentally I was quite immature as
well I looked at things differently and
then it made me realize okay next time I
have sex I need to be aware like do I
want to have a baby with this person do
I want to marry this person do I want to
you know just all these things sort of
come up and I was like I really need to
think about those decisions and and yeah
and what about the second guy were you
with him or no
um yeah the second guy yeah so what made
you not wanna because it seemed like he
did he love you or like he was in a
relationship so the the so we were
actually together before and then we
ended up coming back and then yeah so I
wasn't actually with him but we ended up
coming back oh you dated him before yeah
and I was it was like my longest
relationship so is he was he a good guy
no oh okay no no no he wouldn't have
stuck around no he was no no okay yeah
um so you did the same thing yeah did
the same thing yeah okay exactly so you
kind of grow up from it you sort of
learned the lesson and like I've been
celibate for so long now right because I
look at things so differently now when
it comes to sex and it's not just the
baby but it's the sexual energy is
everything is is sex is really really
sacred people think it's fun but it's
how long have you been celibate for
um if you want it you don't have to
answer this
um well it's it could have been a year
but it's now five months but it could
have been a year so I had a little bleep
but yeah okay okay yeah um and then oh
you also had an abortion yeah can I ask
you about it is it okay yeah um what
made you think you couldn't have a kid
with that guy
oh there were a few factors actually so
um
number one was the guy that I was with
at the time was it was much
an older guy how old oh gosh
that's 26 27. okay that's that's yeah
you're 19. yeah that's not so bad okay
um or if yeah if number is yeah yeah 26
27 all close yeah maybe about close to
30 or 30 anyway but he was much more
older than me
um and
I remember when we discussed
the whole I'm pregnant thing we stepped
out of the doctor's room and he said to
me oh you've got your whole life ahead
of you
um you're too young
um so
that put me off
um and then
I had I had a late term abortion there
so I was like 20 weeks
um I had left the country because I was
actually struggling with whether or not
I'm making the right choice
um also it was
um just how my peers would view me at
the time
and
um my family I have a very strong family
unit
the way I was raised
um I was raised from in a Christian home
and um
I just didn't want to disappoint my mum
uh
and I remember my my mom at the time she
made a statement
and that really just was like a deal
breaker for me I was just like oh if if
you
if you're saying it like that because
she didn't know outrightly but I think
just having a mother's intuition she
sort of she knew there was something
going on
and once she said that I was just like
oh I can't do this this is I've
at the time I felt like I I wasn't
hearing what I wanted to hear which was
who was going to support me how am I
going to cope
um
and yeah I went hasn't
went for the abortion
um did the guy like do you think he
would have stayed if you kept it
I don't actually know
you say actually no or you don't know no
I don't I don't know I mean I chose not
to continue a relationship with him so
after my experience so yeah I would know
um I'm just curious if it was a
different guy do you think he would have
been more likely to keep it
like to both of you
when you say a different guy I think if
it was a different guy who had like a
different
response I would have kept so if he had
the response yeah like I'll be there you
can keep it you would have you would
have kept I think so yeah okay and what
about if it was a guy that you were oh
sure you could have could have seen
yourself with long term maybe yeah like
I shouldn't really like it shouldn't
really make a difference right but I
guess yeah at the time yeah yeah yeah
but like I said I was quite immature
back then even when I had the little
bleep now it was actually someone that I
looked as to the future you know so it
was a bit different but um yeah I
probably would but it shouldn't really
come down to that is my point really no
I think
um
that's what they say in like red pill
that abortion is um the ultimate like
hypergamy where it's like women
um want to be with the like best
long-term mate that they can
so I'm not really surprised by that
answer
can I come in I think what it shows as
well is that you know that we we call it
pro-choice but that choice is never made
in a vacuum you know it was it was the
pressures of those around the thoughts
and the and the feelings that are
particularly the man in in Laura's
instance her mother as well and even I
can say from my experience and um when
when I got pregnant and I told my family
um yeah I mean I was very blessed that
my
um Dad said to me
um yeah we're gonna be there for you
we're going to support you and I know
that that like helped me
um and so I think it's it is a societal
issue and I think this whole pro-choice
rhetoric um rhetoric it kind of puts
everything on the woman when as a
society you know abortion impacts
Society
and it is is there's so many pressures
there's just so many pressures on the
woman and the woman's left to deal with
a lot herself at the end where you know
what of the dad that wasn't there to
support what of the friends and the
family members that weren't there to
support we often hear uh women say you
know if I just had one person that say
you can do this or we'll be here for you
they might have made a different choice
yeah um it's interesting the girls I
know that have had abortions
um not I just met you guys so like but
like I don't
um
I don't think it was like like both of
them came from like pretty wealthy
families that could have helped them I
just think it was more of like life
inconvenience to be fair
um just at the time
but
yeah I think support for those women
isn't even just money though is it it's
emotional support it's just that well
because people can be rich and and could
potentially support but are they you
know these rich families can still say
you know it's going to look bad on our
family or you know there's all those
shame elements and
um that perfect
the the detached on that perfect that
dream for that perfect family that this
is an interruption from that
and so I just think there's a lot of
elements that come in as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible